okay [ __ ] yes we're playing the
midnight shift with Lenny
Mott's actually let me just move this
over okay not that one
where is it there we go mo this over
here thank you very much
okay we're back at Bebe's we're back at
all right this is a game show game on
game Joe okay don't do this thing goes
for your jam 2 is 18 let's do this now
[ __ ] [ __ ] dark already what the [ __ ]
also if you hear the washing machine in
the background it's cuz there's the
washing machine going on in the
background uh hello sir
why my social [ __ ] short what the
[ __ ] alright hello sir what is that
enjoy him they would get one free $5
that's the real nightmare vicious seance
the [ __ ] is that noise [ __ ] dark
acheté this way tell who comes on down
can I get out of here how they [ __ ] my
ass alright hello sir
is that you
okay don't open that dart there's
someone in there and I thought that I'm
trying to win that big prize he can go
screw himself
now wake it there this guy's you've got
to stand strong you just got to stand
strong have a peg it's a track I need
that sorry I got a lot of bills to pay I
got a win there holy [ __ ] [ __ ] laughs
hello sir who is he he's gonna find out
to his no dummy
scary lot of [ __ ] [ __ ] in here
what is this give it a in there I think
I hear someone walking around
okay okay now to find all the hidden
goodies yeah if I get let's do this
Amanda what others I don't say [ __ ]
what's that [ __ ] Wynyard what am i
yelling what what am i doing what
[ __ ] thing needs to be restocked holy
[ __ ] there's two of them
okay we're [ __ ] either if I lose take
another one where's the bank room and
guess it has tech segment okay let's say
this is dick they got me
okay they got me and I don't like that
let's do this [ __ ] all right I can try
again
hug another hangover Jesus
how about their hip place whole [ __ ]
game over again hello sir
[Music]
where's the [ __ ] shelter is your
stocking
all right here holy [ __ ] [ __ ] louder
than last time
thank you [ __ ] himself
okay I'm here to win okay first after
blowing that last challenge I'm not
blowing it again
where's the [ __ ] that needs our stocking
okay sorry buddy
my static can happen now where's the
restocking section just trying to race
doc some things okay
so you're not getting [ __ ] murder
this time I think I'll [ __ ] themselves
I'm not trying to get murdered okay I
got murder they fightin nothing dark in
there now
okay yes another one appeared right
there
nice
okay so right now
okay the [ __ ] is just over there mean
noise I don't understand what the [ __ ]
to do here
[ __ ] hiding the [ __ ] okay now what
so you just put some nut what the [ __ ]
holy [ __ ]
but now
to [ __ ] now
I think he got a not pay that damn
because if he do you [ __ ] get toast
he can't to watch it for all [ __ ]
holy [ __ ] getting the [ __ ] out of here
they [ __ ]
how do you get my weapons
I'm surviving I did it famous I did it
first i money
I am a star now I get the big box
holy Toledo okay a little game hope
you'll join it became Len a guessing
mask is nice some monetary prize man
died sir I guess Fame
pretty let's fortune I guess ok bye guys
I'll see if I can pay these bells down I
bye